r donc Monsieur le Directeur Général et
Monsieur le Directeur nous sommes très
heureus de vous accueillir dans le cadre
de cette mission
d'information que nous avons donc mise
en place au niveau de la commission des
affaires économiques à la demande du
président Larcher au mois de décembre
dernier nous avons commencé les audition
à la mi-décembre sur spécifiquement la
crise du logement nous prévoyons de
rendre notre rapport à la fin du mois de
mars et à l'issue de cette présentation
du rapport
soit nous déclinerons un certain nombre
de nos propositions et de nos mesures
dans le casre d'une proposition de loi
soit nous avions aussi initialement
penser mettre par moie d'amendement
certaines de ces propositions dans le
grand projet de loi logement qui nous
avait été annoncé par l'ancien ministre
du Logement bon force de constater
qu'aujourd'hui pour l'heure il y a
toujours pas de ministre du Logement
d'autre part je ne suis pas si sûr que
ce cal endrier tiennent de nouveau la
route lorsqu'on connaîtra le nouveau
ministre du logement ou le l'ex futur je
ne sais pas et donc voilà on va attendre
mais pour autant nous continuons nos
travaux nous les continuons d'une façon
transpartisane comme on a souvent
l'occasion de le faire au Sénat et c'est
donc cette mission d'information que
nous avons que nous réalisons toutes les
trois donc Vivian Artigalas qui est
sénatrice socialiste des Hautes Pyrénées
Amel gaaker qui est sénatrice centriste
du patcalé et moi-même président de la
commission des affaires économiques et
sénatrice LR des Alpes Maritimes donc
nous sommes très heureuse de pouvoir
vous accueillir monsieur le directeur
général et Monsieur le Directeur du
développement des stratégies publiques
et territoriale de votre groupe Altarea
cogédim donc nous avons un double
objectif d'analyse de la crise actuelle
en allant au-delà du déclencheur
apparent qui a été la hausse brutale des
taux d'intérêt pour nous intéresser aux
causes plus structurelles et plus
anciennes mais aussi avoir des
propositions de mesures de court terme
contracyclique face à la crise et de
plus long terme permettant de
rééquilibrer l'offre et la demande de
logement donc on vous remercie pour les
les documents que vous nous avez déjà
transmis avec des propositions précises
sur laquelle vous allez très
certainement revenir vous évoquez
notamment dans ces documents
l'application partielle des plu on vient
d'ailleurs d'en parler avec l'ancien
ministre du Logement Benoît Apparu c'est
une réalité mais peut-on concevoir de
débloquer la situation autrement que par
une nouvelle obligation notamment en
incitant maire et citoyens à accepter
plus de densité beaucoup disent
également que les mêmes freins agissent
pour empêcher la transformation de
bureaux et peut-être demain de zones
comm commercial en logement ceci
rapportant à la commune les les bureaux
même vide tandis que des logements coûte
avez-vous été confronté à ce type de
difficultés par ailleurs aujourd'hui le
logement intermédiaire est
particulièrement à la mode puisqu'on
vient même d'entendre le Premier
ministre dans sa déclaration de
politique générale parler en quelques
phrases d'une crise du logement d'un
choc de l'offre et annoncé que quelques
petites mesures si ce n'est après des
propos incantatoires sur la
simplification sur la densification mais
parler des logements intermédiaires en
disant qu'il pourrait être intégré tout
ou partie dans le cota de logement
SRE donc ce logement intermédiaire est
assurément nécessaire mais la demande de
logement social porte surtout sur les
logements qui sont moins chers les plai
qu'en pensez-vous est-ce qu'elle t
intervient dans ce domaine et produit en
VEFA pour les opérateurs
HLM enfin il y a un point que vous
n'évoquez pas peut-être dans vos
documents le transfert de la fiscalité
foncière de la mutation à la détention
qu'en pensez-vous estce selon vous un
élément déterminant de libération
foncière puisque le sujet reste d'abord
et avant tout le foncier la matière
première Essen C et donc nous sommes
aussi très à la demande de ce que vous
pourrez nous dire à ce niveau-là donc je
vous laisse la parole et ensuite bien
évidemment nous vous
interrogerons je précise que cette
audition elle est retransmise en vidéo
sur le site internet et sur les réseaux
sociaux du Sénat voilà Monsieur le
Directeur général je vous laisse bien
volontiers la parole merci madame la
Présidente merci beaucoup de de me
recevoir je présente en deux mots
Altarea on a un slide à l'écran c un
groupe qui fait à peu près 3 milliards
d'euros de Chi d'affaires qui est côté
en bourse qui a été fondé il y a
maintenan 25 ans 30 ans presque par
Alain Taravella qui en est toujours
l'actionnaire à 46 % et le président
fondateur on fait plein d'activités
différentes euh notamment nous sommes
une foncière de commerce on possède des
grands centres commerciaux et des gares
c'est nous qui avons avec la SNCF fait
la gare monarnasse les commerces de la
gare monarnass on fait aussi du bureau
on a été sur les années le plus grand
producteur de bureau un peu moins en ce
moment on fait des Data Center des
énergies renouvelable de la gestion
d'actifs de la réhabilitation de
logement ancien y compris historique
avec une filère qui s'appelle histoire
et patrimoine et beaucoup de logement
nous sommes le deuxème promoteur
français de logement selon tous les
classements avec nos différentes marques
qui sont kogedim pitimo et wom ces deux
dernières venant d'être fusionné et
histoire patrimoine pour la
réhabilitation d'ancien
euh alors après je crois que vous
souhaitiez que je vous dise un petit mot
sur l'impact de la crise sur notre
activité je vais faire ça très vite pu
c'est pas vraiment le sujet on est
frappé de plein fouet par cette crise du
logement
euh on publie nos résultats on a une
société côté le 27 février donc je peux
pas dire grand-chose mais simplement les
mécanismes c'est que ce que nous avons
démarré nous le déstockons à perte nous
le vendons à perte euh au bayur sociaux
en bloc euh avec une perte substantielle
ou au particulierier en baissant les
prix de jusqu'à ce qu'il y ait une une
réponse une un écoulement
euh il y a pas mal d'opérations que nous
n'avons pas encore démarré que nous
abandonnons parce que en fait tout ce
que nous avons conçu dans le passé euh
n'est plus adapté à la situation euh est
trop cher ne trouve pas de débouché ne
trouve pas d'acheteur que ce soit les
particuliers accédant ou investisseurs
ou que ce soit parfois les les
investisseurs quand on dit investisseurs
c'est d'ailleurs un abus langage
puisqu'il y a que deux grands groupes
d'acheteurs c'est CDC habitat et Action
Logement tous les autres ont disparu les
Anglo-Saxons les assureurs les fonds de
pension qui sont revenus brièvement dans
les années 2017 2018-29 dans le logement
sont repartis aussi vite pour une raison
assez simple c'est que ça le rendement
est
insuffisant donc nous déstockons nous
abandonnons nous restructurons nous
renégocions c'est parfois difficile
d'être parmi les premiers à porter les
mauvaise nouvelle à savoir qu'on peut
plus payer tel prix pour le foncier ou
qu'on peut plus faire des Grands
Appartements chers aux Mair qui veulent
toujours des Grands Appartements alors
que ça ne se vend pas il n'y a pas de
demande la fragmentation de la société
française la famille française en 40 ans
est spectaculaires et ce sont des T1 des
T2 et des T3 dont on a besoin pas des T4
et des T5 pour lesquels il y a beaucoup
moins de demande et le stock de l'ancien
subvient largement à la demande donc on
veut nous faire faire des grands
appartement comme ça après on les vend
pas on doit les brader ou les découper
alors que c'était pas prévu donc on
lutte contre ça on lutte aussi contre
les chartes euh les chartes ce sont des
règles posées par certains maires ou
certains aménageurs euh de respecter tel
surface telle hauteur sous plafond telle
architecture et cetera et tout ça coûte
à la fin très très cher donc aujourd'hui
renégocier c'est essayer de faire sauter
toutes ces contraintes pour essayer de
de réduire le coût des projets et de
pouvoir baisser le prix de projets de
rencontrer des clients qui peuvent
acheter notre métier finalement c'est
assez simple c'est trouver des terrain
obtenir des permis construire avec les
risques ça suppose respecter des normes
j'en dirais un mot parce que il y en a
trop trop vite trop fort et trouver des
acheteurs qui peuvent acheter voilà ou
des acheteurs qui peuvent acheter pour
louer et ça ça paraît très simple mais
en fait c'est aujourd'hui assez complexe
donc voilà l'impact on a des terrains
dont la valeur est pas la même si on
fait un projet ou si on fait pas on a
des opérations lancées sur lesquels on
s'aperçoit que parce qu'on doit baisser
les prix ou parce que ça coûte plus cher
ou parce que il faut respecter telle ou
telle norme EN PLUS ou tel ou tel désir
de la collectivité ou de la ménageur en
fait on est en perte et donc on passe
beaucoup de perte et vous verrez dans
nos résultats le 27 février si ça vous
intéresse que ça fait des gros dégâts
heureusement nous sommes une société
diversifiée qui a des fonds propres
importants et et qui passera cette crise
qui fera partie des survivants ce sera
pas le cas de de tout le monde va y
avoir une grosse casse dans la
profession je pense que vous en avez
déjà entendu parler donc je je passe sur
maintenant Altara et l'impact de la
crise parce que j'aimerais commencer par
vous montrer cette c c ce petit slide
qui dit en gros que on a quand même le
chic en France pour faire tout à
l'envers on a soutenu la demande avec le
Pinel quand en fait la demande était là
puisque le crédit était abondant il
était pas
cher donc on avait pas besoin de
soutenir la demande et on supprime le
Pinel quand on a besoin de soutenir la
demande donc c'est quand même assez
assez particulier le PTZ le Pr à tau zé
voilà on avait du crédit à 1 %
abondant pas accessible à tout le monde
mais à beaucoup de gens et donc le prê à
taux zéro ça avait un intérêt modeste
c'est comme le PE plus personne ne s'en
servait vraiment et au moment où les
taux passe à 4 % on supprime le PTZ où
on parle de supprimer le PTZ et là la
profession hurle en disant que c'est une
mesure proc cyclique caractérisé c'est
procyclique c'est une mesure qui aggrave
la crise et et donc là on ressuscite le
de PTZ et il faut rendre à César ce qui
est à César il y a eu trois mesures
intéressantes à ce jour qui ont été
prise
par le gouvernement précédent et c'est
c'est la ressuscitation du du PTZ euh
l'accent mis sur logement intermédiaire
avec notamment la stimulation de CDC
habitat et d'Action Logement pour en
acheter euh et puis enfin c'est un peu
technique la modification du zonage pour
que plus de villes soi accessible à ces
dispositifs et notamment au PTZ et au
logement intermédiaire c'est les fameux
classements AA à moin B1 B2 et cetera
qui vous sont peut-être familiers mais
il reste évidemment beaucoup à faire
mais moi ce qui me frappe c'est ça c'est
et puis alors quand finalement on était
dans l'abondance
avec j'ai j'ai coutume de dire qu'on
nachetait pas vraiment un appartement on
le faisait porter par sa banque on
pouvait en descend éter à 110 % y
compris les frais de notaire à 1 % de
taux d'intérêt sur 25 ans rembourser
quand on voulait quasiment sans pénalité
et renégocier si les taux baissaient
c'est c'est magique c'est c'est un
système fantastique donc et puis tout
d'un
coup et et peut et à la fin il y avait
une espérance de plus-value donc un
système où la banque portait pour pas
cher et à la fin il y avait une
plusvalue aujourd'hui évidemment tout a
changer le 1 % est devenu 4 le crédit
n'est plus disponible pour tout le monde
il faut mettre 15 ou 20 % personnel
passer la rampe des critères du Haut
Conseil de stabilité financière qui soit
dit en passant me semble trop ailé et et
trop rigide
et et c'est beaucoup plus difficile
probablement qu'il a une plus valalue un
jour à la clé mais ça donne beaucoup
moins envie qu'avant donc tout a changé
mais moi j'aime bien dire que il n'y a
pas que les taux d'intérêt qui ont
changé la donne il y a un empilement de
choses que nous avons fait dans les
années 2010
2020 inflationnistes qui ont fait monter
très fort les coûts et les prix euh
puisqu'on pouvait se le permettre parce
que le crédit était abondant et et donc
on faisait tout on disait oui à tout le
monde oui au chartes oui au T4 T5 oui
aux architectures extrêmement coûteuses
oui au rapports qui disait qu'il fallait
augmenter beaucoup les hauteurs sous
plafond parce que c'était plus joli et
cetera et tout ça passait parce que le
client pouvait acheter puisquil était
solvabilisé par le crédit donc c'est
moins le la hausse des taux que ce ce ce
cette rupture entre une période où
l'argent était abondant et l'argent est
rare il était là pour tout le monde ou
presque et il est plus là pour tout le
monde et cetera donc voilà en en matière
d'environnement c'est pareil pendant ces
10 ans on aurait pu beaucoup faire pour
euh contre le réchauffement climatique
et pour le climat et on n rien fait les
climatosceptiques nous ont fait perdre
beaucoup de temps précieux et alors
aujourd'hui c'est paradoxal on veut
rattraper et alors on empile les normes
environnementales tous les 2 ans ça
change on en rajoute une à chaque fois à
chaque marche de l'escalier ça coûte 5 à
10 % de plus
et on a avec la re 2020 échelon 22
désolé pour caractère technique la norme
la plus exigeante d'Europe aujourd'hui
et bien on a à peine pris la mesure de
cette norme qu'on va en avoir une
nouvelle le 1er janvier 2025 ça
s'appelle La2
25 qui coûte encore 5 7 10 % ça dépend
des catégories et qui va tomber au pire
moment euh c'est-à-dire au moment où les
gens ne n'ont plus les moyens d'acheter
donc moi j'ai tendance à penser qu'on
était à un bon niveau avec la re 22
qu'on visait le Graal de 28 31 qui est
très décarbonant et qui est très
difficile à atteindre et qu'il est
inutile
et contreproductif de venir normer le
chemin de l'un à l'autre et et donc je
pense qu'on devrait enjambber ne pas
tenir compte de la re25 et visé à terme
la re 28 et 31 mais c'est paradoxal de
se dire quand on avait les moyens on
stimulait la demande on CR on
fournissait du prêt à taux zéro dont on
avait pas besoin on faisait pas d'effort
sur l'environnement et maintenant qu'on
a plus la demande ou plus la solvabilité
des acheteurs on supprime la stimulation
de la demande on a failli supprimer le
prêt au zéro et c'est là qu'on veut
rattraper le temps perdu et faire de
l'environnement de prendre des mesures
de préservation de l'environnement et du
climat qui qui sont légitimes logiques
que je respecte parfaitement mais qui
tombent pas au bon moment et et c'est
pareil j'aime bien dire il faut tout
acteur de la société doit trouver son
chemin dans un équilibre de contrainte
le l'environnemental le social et
l'économique et si on fait une embardée
dans un sens ouou un autre on crée des
grandes perturbations ça s'appelle les
gilets jaunes ça peut s'appeler les
agriculteurs et en matière de logement
ça s'appelle le DPE ça s'appelle la re25
ça s'appelle des choses qui vont
paralyser un système déjà bien malad et
qui sont procycliques qui vont aggraver
la crise et qui sont donc mal calibré
mal calendarisés euh et donc par exemple
moi je propose d'abroger les mesures sur
le DPEG au 1er janvier 25 parce que
c'est mal construit c'est mal fait il y
a plein de problèmes d'application il y
a même des
magouilles et et c'est juste
inimaginable dans un pays où qui est
complètement carencé en matière de de
logement d'en retirer de du parc locatif
ça c'est juste pas
possible donc reprenons arrêtons tout ça
reprenons notre souffle reconstruisons
un système qui marche qui soit
raisonnable qui soit applicable alord
riser comme il faut euh plutôt que
d'essayer de rafistoiler quelque chose
qui est très mal
né donc voilà ça c'est un petit peu le
le le côté paradoxal de la politique du
logement si tentez qu'il y en ait une
c'est euh c'est c'est paradoxal voilà et
donc si on regarde je crois que vous
vous avez déjà
eu beaucoup beaucoup d'auditions et donc
je vais pas m'étendre sur sur la nature
de la crise aujourd'hui tout le monde il
y a un consensus sur le fait que que la
crise est là que c'est une bombe sociale
que ça peut faire exploser la la cité la
société
euh nous faisons partie des gens qui
disant ça depuis 2 ans euh et je pense
que c'est plus la peine d'insister
là-dessus la bombe est là elle est en
train de d'exploser il y a des
d'énormes d'énormes conséquences sur
notre société l'emploi le travail les
études et et juste la la vie quotidienne
des gens donc euh je m' je m'apesantirai
pas là-dessus je voudrais juste vous
montrer cette matrice qui montre que la
crise touche absolument tout le parcours
résidentiel que ce soit l'ancien le neuf
c'est ce que j'ai ici en absciss euh le
social et on pourrait même dire le
solidaire le très social euh
l'intermédiaire le libre et aussi euh
l'accession euh acheter son appartement
ou l'investissement acheté pour mettre
en location et louer autr et loger
autrui tout ça est coincé bloqué
euh et les conséquences en bas de cette
page vous les connaissez et je vais pas
immédi attendre parce que je voudrais
passer l'essentiel du temps que vous
m'accordez sur les solutions euh d'après
nous et donc ça c'est la même
matrice avec une tentative
euh de d'apporter un certain nombre de
solutions mais je vrais faire un détour
si vous le voulez bien par une
comparaison avec la situation dans le
reste de l'Europe et même un peu au-delà
de l'Europe parce que cette crise n'est
pas typiquement française les taux
d'intérêt on augmenté partout l'accès au
crédit s rarifié partout le créduit
abondant a créé les mêmes déséquilibres
à peu près partout et la plupart des des
pays dont je vais vous parler dans une
seconde sont dans même crise et c'est
intéressant de voir comment certains
d'entre eux ont déjà réagi donc si je
prends je vais commencer par un petit
pays dont on se moque parfois en France
mais qui est respectable c'est le
Luxembourg le Luxembourg ils ont la même
crise et qu'est-ce qu' qu'est-ce qu'ils
sont en train de faire densifier ça me
paraît intelligent créer des logements
abordables ça paraît intelligent aussi
soutenir les communes qui créent des
logements abordables en les y aidant
voilà et puis plus spectaculaire
dynamiser la demande à court terme et
donc eux ils ont déjà un statut du
bailleur privé avec un amortissement et
ils sont en train de réviser les taux
d'amortissement pour queon puisse
amortir plus et plus vite et donc avoir
moins de revenus imposable ils sont en
train de baisser le taux d'imposition
des plusvalu ils sont en train de créer
un crédit d'impôt pour favoriser
l'investissement des PER personne
physique en direct dans le locatif et
ils ont bien raison parce que s'il y a
pas de propriétaire qui achète des
logements pour les mettre en location il
y a pas d'ppartement en location sur le
marché et vous savez comme moi je suis
sûr que mes collègues prédécesseurs vous
l'ont souligner il y a aujourd'hui au
moins 10 demandes pour chaque logement
proposé à la location et parfois 11 174
comme le cité le Figaro pour un
appartement dans le quartier de
Belleville ce qui est assez
spectaculaire sur une demi-journée
comment sur une demi-journée sur une
demi-journée exactement
euh les intérêts débiteurs des
accueureurs d'habitation principal sont
déductibles fiscalement et ils
augmentent le quota de déductibilité
donc ils sont en avance sur nous sur
beaucoup de choses et ils accroissent
cette cette avance voilà ils soutiennent
les primos accédants
euh ils ils ont interrogé la Commission
européenne sur la possibilité de baisser
la TVA pour les primau accédentss parce
qu'on personne ne vous en a souvent
sûrement que personne ne vous a parlé de
la TVA parce que c'est à vous on parle
pas de TVA c'est le bastion de de Bercy
mais quand on y réfléchit bien si on dit
le logement c'est vital ça fait partie
avec
l'alimentation l'éducation la santé des
besoins vitaux de de d'un pays et de ses
citoyens pourquoi on est à 20 % ou
pourquoi on est à 20 % sur surtout SAF
le social et l'intermédiaire ou pourquoi
le taux de l'intermédiaire est-il
réservé à des investisseurs
professionnels que sont les bailleurs
sociaux pourquoi pas à tout le monde bon
je passe sur le
Luxembourg au Canada c'est un peu plus
loin c'est c'est encore plus ils sont
ils ont mis entre parenthèses à peu près
la totalité de leur norm et donc pendant
une période limitée pour essayer de
relancer le logement
voilà favoriser la Location Longue Durée
bonne idée plutôt que la location courte
durée je suis sûr que on vous en a parlé
accompagner financièrement les acheteurs
avec un crédit hypothécaire un peu
innovant augmenter la production des
logements
abordables en Irlande tout faire pour
diminuer le prix de revien des
opérations de logement bonne
idée augmenter les aides pour rénover le
parc existant ça on le fait développer
le logement intermédiaire bonne idée
aussi en Allemagne dont on qu'on cite
comme modèle notamment à verersi en
disant eux ils dépensent moins et c'est
la même chose voà et bien ils ont décidé
de débloquer 19 milliards d'euros pour
investir dans dans le secteur du
logement euh ce qui est une somme assez
considérable euh ils ont mis entre
parenthèses un certain nombre de normes
environnementales euh ils ont simplifié
et accéléré les règles applicables au
logement
abordable mis en place des aides
supplémentaires à l'accession et la
propriété donc une sorte de PTZ avec des
plafonds de de revenus assez élevé
euh comme c'est le cas du nouveau PTZ
d'ailleurs qui est plutôt
bien et un programme d'aide à
l'accession à la propriété et un
programme d'aide aux investisseurs
privés particulier
tiens avec l'introduction d'un taux
d'amortissement dégressif de 6 % par an
et cetera alors je vais bientôt arrêter
en Angleterre pareil ils ont mis entre
parenthèses un certain nombre de règles
environnementales pour essayer de
débloquer le système et en Espagne pour
vous montrer qu'ils n'ont pas tous
raison ils ont tout faux voilà puisque
ils ont accru l'encadrement des loyers
et protéger davantage les locataires
alors ça j'ai je m'intéresse parce que
on sait que ça ça marche pas et que
c'est complètement contreproductif ça
marche quelques années puis après ça
crée des des effets bien pires chez nous
ça s'appelle la loi de 1948 ça a asséché
la production de logement conduit à
l'obligation de créer dans les années 60
des grands ensembles pour leoget des
milliers de personnes issus de l'exode
rural notamment et on sait que c'est la
paralysie totale à terme bloquer les
loyers et protéger davantage le
locataire ça va dans la mauvaise
direction ça dissuade les acteurs et les
investisseurs d'investir dans dans le
logement donc ce qui est intéressant
dans cette comparaison avec les autres
pays c'est que ils sont grosso modo dans
la même situation que nous et on voit
les familles de solutions qui sont
proposées alors si on regarde la case
logement social dans
l'ancien c'est pas forcément ma
spécialité mais je crois que le problème
c'est que tout est verrouillé tout est
bloqué les gens restent indéfiniment
dans le social même quand il dépasse les
plafonds de revenus puisqu'on applique
pas ou peu ou avec plein d'exemptions
les ce qu'on appelle les surloyer ou les
les fins de bail qui est parce que on
est à partir de 200 % du revenu on doit
sortir ça c'est assez mal appliqué donc
on bloque dans le logement social les
gens on n produit pas assez et donc il y
a les grande stabilité du système le
l'occupant moyen du logement social a 50
ans il vieillit chaque année donc ce
sont les mêmes qui reste pendant ce
temps-là les gens qui sont dans le
solidaire ou même sous les ponts ne
trouvent pas à se loger et il y a une
assez bonne raison à ça malgré tout
c'est que tant qu'on n pas créé
suffisamment de logement
intermédiaire ce parcours résidentiel
est interrompu il y a un chaom mancant
donc il faut absolument et c'est plutôt
engagé mais il faut aller plus loin
développer un maximum de logement
intermédiaire pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
rupture dans la chaîne du parcours
résidentiel après donc vous m'avez posé
une question je en profiter pour y
répondre moi je crois
que le il y a deux solutions sur la loi
SRU pas celle qu'a évoqué le nouveau
Premier ministre et qui je pense va
corriger le tir parce qu'il s'est rendu
compte du sujet la première solution
c'est de dire on ajoute au quota de 25 %
de logement social un quota de logement
intermédiaire et donc la loi su article
55 est amendé pour qu'on fasse 25 % de
logement social et par exemple 10 % de
logement intermédiaire ça c'est la
première solution mais pas 10 % dans les
25 parce que là on vient
perturber un autre bout du parcours
résidentiel et finalement ça ça marche
pas l'autre solution c'est celle pour
laquelle je milite depuis maintenant 2
ans euh peut-être que d'autres vous en
ont parlé c'est de rendre neutre créer
une troisème catégorie qui s'appelle
logement intermédiaire neutre au sens de
la loi SRU donc le le libre crée le
besoin de faire 25 % de social euh mais
l'intermédiaire aussi et ça c'est pas
normal quand on fait 100 logements en
libre il faut faire 25 logements en
social mais si on fait 75 logements en
libre et 25 en intermédiaire il faut
toujours faire 25 de logement social je
pense qu'on pourrait neutraliser les
logements intermédiaires il ne compte
pas dans le cota social mais il ne
génère pas de besoin de faire plus de
social c'est une mesure assez simple il
faut juste l'imaginer trois catégories
une négative une positive et une neutre
qui c'est c'est et je pense ça serait le
le bon
équilibre pour stimuler le le logement
intermédiaire euh alors après sur le
logement
intermédiaire je ne vois pas pourquoi on
réserverait cette catégorie à les
investisseurs professionnels on peut
très bien offrir la possibilité à tous
les Français particuliers investisseurs
et notamment les classes moyennes
d'acheter un T2 de le mettre en location
de respecter les les plafonds de revenus
et de loyers de l'intermédiaire et
d'avoir en contrepartie une TVA à 10 %
au lieu de 20 % et une une un crédit
d'impôt pour compenser la taxe foncière
pourquoi réserve-t-on ça au aux
bailleurs sociaux c'est c'est un mystère
assez étrange qui rejoint une autre
remarque que je vais vous faire dans
dans un
instant après si je descends un peu je
vais dans le social neu je voudrais vous
expliquer que nous sommes l'objet d'un
impôt caché nous devons fabriquer du
social et nous devons le vendre à un
prix qui est l'objet d'une entente entre
un petit nombre de gens et parfois les
responsables des agglomérations et qui
est fixer un niveau où nous perdons
environ 700 € par mètre
carré donc en moyenne en France quand un
promoteur fabrique un logement social et
le vend un bailleur social le prix est
fixé
par le bailleur social responsable de
l'urbanisme de l'aglo l'agglomération et
cetera un niveau qui nous met en perte
de 700 € par mètre carré et donc nous
devons augmenter de 250 ou 300 € le prix
du logement libre que Monsieur ou Madame
Dupont achète euh et et et ça participe
de l'inflation des prix je ne vois pas
pourquoi on pourrait pas fixer comme
règle de vendre au prix de revient sans
marge voilà et c'est d'autant plus
choquant que quand les bailleurs sociaux
font la maîtrise d'ouvrage direct qu'ils
construisent eux-mêmes le logements
sociaux euh ben ça leur coûte le prix de
revient le même que le nôtre voilà euh
nous fabriquons nous promoteurs 56 % des
logements sociaux neufs en France voilà
et pourquoi ce chiffre est si élevé
c'est parce que c'est très intéressant
pour les bailleurs sociaux ça leur coûte
moins cher que sil les fabriqué eux-même
mais c'est l'acheteur de de de logement
libre euh qui paye à l'arrivée donc ça
participe de l'inflation donc on
pourrait fixer comme règle que les VEFA
sociales s'appelle comme ça se vend au
prix de revient ni plus ni
moins alors s'agissant
maintenant de de la question
de
l'accession l'accession les outils pour
favoriser l'accession c'est le PTZ je
pense que ça c'est bien le prê à tau zé
surtout quand les taux sont à 4 % c'est
probablement la possibilité de
développer une accession à prix
abordable que j'ai appelé ici
l'accession intermédiaire
l'intermédiaire c'est pas seulement du
locatif ça peut aussi être de la
propriété de l'accession on pourrait
très bien imaginer un système ça se
pratique dans les villes communistes où
on respecte les prix maîtrisés qui sont
abordabl qui sont en priorité réservés
au citoyens au citadin de la ville en
question et qui sont inférieurs au prix
du marché si serait reflété dans le prix
du foncier qu'en général la ville cède
au promoteur ça marche très bien s'il y
a une modération foncière on peut faire
une modération tarifaire à l'arrivée et
c'est alors c'est quelque chose qui n'a
aucune base légale on peut tout à fait
désobéir sauf que dans ce cas-là on n
plus invité à travailler dans la ville
en question et en fait nous promoteurs
nous respectons euh plutôt assez
largement ces ces directives et ça
fonctionne très bien donc prenons
l'exemple finalement des pratiques de de
des villes gérées par le les communiste
et et et faisons donant lui une base
légale et faisons de l'accession à prix
intermédiaire mais il reste que le grand
problème du moment c'est que on a
découragé les investisseurs privés et
que si on
écoute notamment le le l'ancien ministre
Patrick vergrit Patrice vergrit ils ne
sont pas bienvenus ils sont supposés
être des mauvais
propriétaires des mauvais presque des
mauvais français euh pour des raisons
qui m'échappent complètement alors c'est
exactement l'inverse qui sont les seuls
investisseurs capables de se contenter
d'un rendement modeste parce qu'il
cherchent à se construire un patrimoine
pour la retraite les classes moyennes
qui achètent des T2 des T3 pour les
mettre en location et ils sont nombreux
ils ont des moyens qui individuellement
sont assez modestes mais qui la masse
sont très importants bien supérieurs à
ceux de l'État ou même au bailleurs
sociaux et donc je pense exactement
l'inverse exactement l'inverse il faut
cajoler l'investisseur privé qui achète
pour louer il faut le cajoler alors le
cajolet ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
d'abord ne pas lui taper dessus toute la
journée en disant que c'est un mauvais
un mauvais acteur du logement ça veut
dire lui accorder un statut ce qui
s'appelle le statut du bailleur privé
qui peut aller comme on a vu tout à
l'heure dans certains pays avec la
possibilité de pratiquer un
amortissement accéléré pour effacer ses
revenus fonciers donc ne être moins
imposé ou plus tard ça peut être aussi
rééquilibrer le la relation propriétaire
locataire parce que vous savez qu'en
France si si vous subissez des impayés
c'est quand même très compliqué
récupérer les loyers euh et si si vous
êtes en fin de bail vous ne pouvez
reprendre la possession de votre
appartement qu'en y mettant un ascendant
ou un descendant ou en vendant nous
sommes le seul pays de l'Union
européenne où après le bail c'est pas
fini ça continue en fait ça c'est
incroyable après 9 an de bail parce que
outre outre asymétrie le locataire peut
partir à peu près enfin interval
régulier ça dépend si on est enem meublé
ou pas le propriétaire doit aller au
bout du bail mais à la fin du bail c'est
pas
fini c'est compliqué de récupérer son
son logement à la fin du bail ce qui est
quand même un problème on peut soit il
faut soit s'y installer soit installer
un ascendant un descendant soit le
mettre en vente ça c'est une aberration
et il faut arrêter
ça et donc deuxème le statut du bailleur
privé la relation propriétaire Baer et
avec le statut du Baur privé un certain
nombre d'incitations euh le les classes
moyennes qui achetaient du Pinel c'était
des gens dont les revenus du ménage chez
altaria représenter 70 75000 € non euh
pas des défavorisés pas non plus vous en
conviendrez des des ultra
riches
et et donc on parle on parle vraiment de
gens qui sont dans une logique de se
constituer un patrimoine pour la
retraite de se protéger un peu qui se
contentait de 2 et5i % ou 2 % de
rendement fiscalisé avec beaucoup
d'ennui dans la relation propriétaire
locataire quand les taux étaient 1 % et
qui ne s'en contentent plus aujourd'hui
donc voilà là il y a un problème il faut
être un peu bizarre pour investir à 2 %
de rendement avoir plein d'ennui payer
plein d'impôts quand les taux d'intérêt
sont à 4 voilà donc là on a un problème
majeur c'est que la source principale de
financement de l'accroissement du parc
locatif qui est l'investisseur privé des
classes moyennes susceptible de donner à
bail pendant 10 ans 20 ans 30 ans pour
se fabriquer ce patrimoine n'a plus
envie de le faire et qu'en plus on
compte pas sur lui pour le faire ce qui
est une qu'une abération donc là on a un
gros travail et tous les pays dont je
vous ai parlé tout à l'heure s'en sont
occupés c'est un de leurs axes
prioritaires et et et nous on est
exactement à 180° tout du moins jusqu'à
jusqu'au changement de
gouvernement et je pense que ça c'est le
le la réforme essentielle à faire la
réhabilitation de l'investisseur privés
en locatif en direct parce que le l'idée
d'aller les faire investir dans des CPI
c'est pas du tout pareil de posséder
soi-même un T2 ou d'avoir trois parts
d'une SCPI
illiquide qui achète un certain nombre
de de T2 ça ne serait-ce que parce que
je connais un petit peu ce métier lesp
nos collègues que si elles sont capables
de générer 5 à 6 % de rendement de
distribuer 5 à 6 % de rendement par an
on voit bien que c'est pas le cas du
logement même en faisant un effort on
nteindra pas 5 à 6 % de de rendement
sauf à donner beaucoup d'avantage
fiscaux très dispendieux ou à augmenter
beaucoup les loyers ce qui dans les deux
cas est quand même un petit peu
compliqué donc voilà un petit peu le la
matrice des solutions qui colle à la
matrice de la
crise alors comme vous le savez parce
que vous l'avez auditionné je crois la
FPI propose un un un effet choc qui est
de réhabiliter la la mesure baladure
Charette de
1994 qui consiste à exempter de droit de
succession tous les acheteurs
d'appartements neuf pendant une très
courte période à l'époque c'était 18
mois c'est un grand avantage c'est que
ça décale la charge pour le budget de
l'État de 20 ou 30 ans jusqu'au au jour
du décès de de l'acquerreur et il est
incontestable que ça créerait un appel
d'air sur la demande encore faut-il
qu'on arrive à
produire et ça c'est le sujet
de du foncier de la densification des
permis et donc là je réponds à votre
autre
question sur les PLU votre première
question c'est quand même une chose un
peu étrange que les mêmes euh fassent un
plan local d'urbanisme et ne
l'appliquent pas quand il délivre quand
ils examine un permis de construire euh
c'est à peu près les mêmes gens qui
travaillent sur le même sujet c'est donc
pourquoi est-ce qu'on dit ben cette
parcelle ou ces parcelles dans cette
zonelà peut avoir telle densité et puis
quand on dépose un permis on vous en
donne les 2 tiers en ayant l'impression
de vous faire une grande faveur c'est
pas logique euh en Italie le master plan
c'est la même chose que le PLU il est
opposable si dans le master plan il y a
écrit qu'on a le droit à une densité de
010 dans le quartier donné et c'est un
droit opposable on peut pas vous refuser
le 010 et vous dire c'est
0065 donc je pense que il serait assez
logique d'appliquer les PLU dans leur
intégralité et pas au 2 tiers comme
comme c'est le cas et c'est totalement
contradictoire avec Lean donc il y a un
moment il faut choisir étalement ou
densité je crois que c'est choisi
d'avance mais pour ça il faut appliquer
les densités prévu au pu d'autant que ce
sont euh grosso modo les mêmes gens qui
euh signent les permis et qui lancent
les révision de PLU
[Applaudissements]
euh
comment alors oui c'est ça oui euh donc
euh l'une l'un des moyen de
ressolvabiliser la demande c'est
d'améliorer ce ce système extrêmement
performant que nous avons en France qui
est le crédit immobilier et et
là nous sommes porteurs et inspirateurs
d'une idée qui va chercher ses sources
en Suisse ou même en
Scandinavie qui commence à faire son
chemin on vous en a peut-être parlé qui
consiste à
dire ach j'achète un appartement je mets
20 % d'apport personnel euh je prends un
premier crédit de 50 % classique 2 an au
fixe
remboursable chaque année par annuité
euh et sur le sol 30 % qui correspond à
peu près à la valeur du terrain euh là
j'ai un autre crédit euh les Suisses
l'appellent le crédit hypothécaire dont
je paye les intérêts euh chaque mois
mais que je ne rembourse pas euh et qui
suit euh le donc en France on est le
crédit immobilé repose sur les revenus
de l'acquéreur et pas sur la valeur du
bien donc là on a introduit sur la
valeur du terrain un crédit sur la
valeur du bien alors ça met personne en
péril parce que la banque elle a en en
hypothèque un bien qui vaut 100 et elle
a prêté 30 en crédit infin si vous
voulez dont elle ne perçoit que les
intérêts et ce crédit étant remboursé
lors de la vente ou même transférer au
nouvel accerur ou même en cas de décès
euh au au successeurs donc ça ça aurait
un effet les les Suisses vont beaucoup
plus loin ils font 65 % en crédit
hypothécaire je pense c'est trop si on
se limite à 30 % on réduit la mensualité
du ménage de 13 % par mois et c'est un
système qui évidemment r resolvabilise
d'autant le ménage et lui permet euh
d'accéder à au crédit ou à plus de
crédit c'est assez simple ça met pas le
système bancaire suisse en péril au
contraire les banquier saurait faire
j'en ai discuté avec plusieurs banquiers
spécialisés en crédit immobilier ça
contrevient probablement au règle du
hcsf puisque un crédit infin ça doit pas
bien être en cohérence avec le le crédit
de 25 ans qui est l'une des règles du
hcsf
ou alors ils vont
recalculer en prof format pour voir ce
que ça donnerait s'il était remboursé et
et et et donc voilà c'est le seul
obstacle c'est le hcsf mais ce système
fait a fait ses preuves sera efficace
peut être calibré raisonnablement un peu
moins qu'en Suisse et euh et
ressolvabiliser certains certains
ménages
euh voilà alors maintenant je vais
répondre à vos autres questions euh
bureau
logement transformation de bureau
logement bon oui on en fait un peu on va
essayer d'en faire plus on estime que le
le gisement c'est 20000 logements
euh 20000 logements c'est à la fois pas
mal et pas décisif
VO je pense qu'on vous a parlé du
dernier la dernière étude sur le besoin
de logement en France qui a été lancé à
l'initiative d'Emmanuel COS de l'Union
sociale pour l'habitat elle a fait
travailler un cabinet qui s'appelle HTC
et et qui a bien travaillé je trouve moi
j'ai lu le rapport c'est très
intéressant et qui chiffre à 518000
logements par an le besoin de logement
en France comme on en est à peu près à
la moitié vous voyez que
transformer 20000 cré 20000 logements
dans la transformation de bureau en
logement ça va ça va aider mais pas plus
alors il y a plein d'obstacles hein
c'est bâtiments trop épais en bureau en
fait 18 m de large c'est beaucoup trop
pour faire du logement donc on doit
rentrer les bureaux les les balcons dans
l'immeuble on perd des mètres carrés il
faut que les bureaux soient bien mal
placés pour que l'équation économique
marche le logement c'est le monde du TTC
20 % de TVA alors que le bureau c'est le
monde de la TVA récupérable du hors taxe
donc ça fait 20 %
d'écart il faut créer 25 % logements
sociaux sur lesquels on perd sa chemise
par mètre carré 700 € je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure et et cetera et cetera et
c'est plus compliqué de réhabiliter un
immeuble dont on ne garde finalement que
la la partie la moins la moins chère qui
est le le béton la la
structure voilà donc
c'est je ne je respecte je je je pense
qu'il y a un marché je pense que c'est
pas inintéressant c'est assez difficile
euh et ça n'est pas une solution à
l'échelle du
problème alors les zones commerciales je
là aussi je crois avoir soufflé cette
idée à oliviaè Grégoire quand elle a été
nommée ça fait de ça 3 ans voilà j'étais
à l'époque le président de la Fédération
des centres commerciaux qui s'appelle
Fédération des acteurs du commerce dans
les
territoires oui on doit mais à l'époque
le logement allait bien le logement
avait un marché les acheteurs étaient
solevables et donc j'avais imaginé que
qu'on utilise ces zones assez pe Danes
que sont les les zonees commercial
d'entrée de ville un peu dévalorisé vous
y voyez à peu près ce que je veux dire
pas les centres commerciaux ni les
centr-ville mais ces boîtes à chaussures
qu'on voit en entrée de ville qui sont
des passoirs thermiques qui sont peu
densifiés qui sont bien desservis en
général une grande route nationale des
transport en commun on doit pouvoir
densifier ces zonesl les reconvertir
encore faut-il que le marché du logement
soit soit
équilibré mais c'est une option sur le
sujet du foncier c'est une
possibilité le lli j'en ai
parlé alors nous nous faisons à peu près
2000 logements sociaux par an que nous
vendons en VEFA ce qu'on appelle les
VEFA social en perdant 700 € par m Carr
en moyenne et en augmentant les prix du
logement de Monsieur Madame Dupont de
300 € à peu près du mètre carré pour
récupérer la perte sur logement social
euh c'est comme ça on a pas le choix
c'est la loi SRU article 55 il faut la
respecter
euh nous trouvons juste un normal de
vendre à perte voilà en principe c'est
interdit de la même manière que les
oligopoles qui s'entendent sur les prix
c'est interdit hein si vous regardez les
lois sur la concurrence en France rien n
en
exclut les les bailleurs sociaux même
quand c'est l'agglomération qui qui fixe
le prix et et donc ça je pense c'est
tout à fait anormal et sur la fiscalité
[Musique]
euh je me méfie un petit peu de cette
idée je je je la trouve à la fois
légitime intellectuellement et quand on
ouvre la la boîte de Pandor d'une
réforme de la fiscalité on sait pas où
on arrive voilà on a euh donc oui ça
serait mieux de taxer la détention et
pas la mutation mais la détention est
déjà beaucoup taxé donc en fait il
faudrait juste taxer moins la mutation
et pas plus la détention et ça on sait
que conttenu du budget de l'État
conttenu des champions du monde de la
créativité fiscale qu'on a à bi je
respecte infiniment mais mais qui
prennent toujours plus finalement je
pense que c'est une direction dangereuse
voou et un peu un miroir au Alouettes
avec des effets pervers
potentiel il y a plein d'autres moyens
je crois de libérer du foncier que
d'aller perturber complètement les
équilibres de la fiscalité
sinon sinon en la réduisant ce qui pas
franchement l'air du temps mais il va
bien falloir y arriver un peu comme
l'automobile le logement a été la vache
àis ou comme le pétrole les carb durant
le logement a été la vachealée fiscale
90 milliards de recettes fiscales
d'ailleurs qui fondent comme neige au
soleil on en parle jamais hein mais on a
déjà perdu au moins 4 milliards de
recettes de TVA avec la baisse de la
production du logement et ça va
s'accroître notre prévision c'est plutôt
10 milliards de moins euh dans les
caisses de l'État lié à la à la baisse
de la production de logement sans parler
des droits de mutation à titre onéreux
qui manque cruellement au département
euh voilà on a entendu des chiffres
absolument
gigantesques et et et et et
donc donc à la fois c'est ennuyeux que
ça
baisse mais mais c'était beaucoup trop
les droits de mutation ils sont beaucoup
trop élevé c'est un un record
européen c'est beaucoup
trop les recettes fiscales provenant du
logement c'est c'est beaucoup trop alors
nous ob que l'Allemagne dépense moins
mais elle prélève beaucoup moins c'est
de l'ordre du simple double l'Allemagne
prélève environ la moitié moins sur sur
le logement voilà et puis après elle
dépense en effet moins jusqu'à ce qu'
décide de rajouter 19 milliards au pot
où là ça
devrait on a un modèle dans lequel on
taxe beaucoup et on redistribue pas
mal peut-être qu'on devrait redistribuer
moins ou
mieux mais le problème c'est sur tout
qu'on taxe beaucoup et quand on asphixie
on asphyie les acteurs économiques et
bien ils font ce que tous les grands
promoteurs s'apprête à faire faute de
débouchés solevable vont réduire leur
production donc ça c'est un peu
là-dessus que je voudrais avant de
répondre à vos questions terminer c'est
il est en train de se passer quelque
chose d'incroyablement paradoxal et
négatif c'està dire qu'alors que le pays
a besoin de plus de logement ceux qui
savent les fabriquer les promoteurs et
et les architectes les notaires les
entreprises du bâtiment et CEA vont en
produire
moins et c'est imparable si on n pas on
est nous sommes des industriels on a une
chaîne de production voyez donc on lance
une voiture ou un avion si et seulement
si on sait qu'il y a un débouché dans
sur une chaîne industrielle il y a un
acheteur une compagnie aérienne ou un
acheteur de bah c'est pareil dans le
logement nous allons lancer des
programme de logement que si nous avons
une assez bonne certitude de trouver
des acheteurs solevables que ce soit en
bloc avec des institutionnels ou des
particuliers et si possible des
particuliers parce que c'est quand même
ça le métier
d'origine et et comme ça n'est pas le
cas ne vont pas déboucher les ventes
sont très
mauvaises les prix en bloc sont très
pénalisants et donc nous sommes dans une
phase où à la fois je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure on Déstock on abandonne des
projets et puis on essaie de réinventer
une nouvelle offre pour demain ou
après-demain qui réponde aux équations
économiques de de demain c'est-à-dire
moins cher parce que fondamentalement ce
qu'on produit est trop
cher et et on peut pas en baisser le
prix puisqu'on a 5 % de marge donc on
est très vite dans le dans une année
normale donc on est très vite dans le
rouge dans l'ancien c'est
différent quelqu'un qui a fait une
plusvalue de X 2 ou x 3 en 20 ans peut
accepter de baisser son prix de 10 ou
15% s'il a vraiment besoin de vendre
nous au-delà de - 5 % on est dans le
rouge on perd de l'argent et c'est quand
même d'abord c'est ruineux pour nos
finances c'est dangereux pour notre
santé économique en tant qu'entreprise
et puis c'est juste pas possible
euh donc il faut baisser les prix il
faut payer les fonciers moins chers si
c'est possible il faut moins nous faire
concurrence les uns et les autres et
créer une inflation sur les rares
fonciers il faut obtenir plus de inité
dans les permis il faut que on accepte
tous que la ville doit peut-être pas se
verticaliser beaucoup mais au moins se
densifier nous avons construit à ici les
molineau un projet absolument magnifique
qui s'appelle ici curdeville qui est
très dense il fait 103000 m² sur un peu
moins de 3 hectares mais quand vous y
êtes c'est ce que j'appelle la densité
heureuse ça se voit pas il y a une forêt
urbaine il y a des espace on a respecté
les trames urbanistiques de la ville et
on n pas l'impression d'être dans un un
site de 103000 m² je pense que on peut
faire de la densité heureuse et ça
résout une partie du problème de de
l'accès au
fonciè les coûts qu'est-ce qu'il y a
dans les coûts du bâtiment il y a peu de
marge des entreprises du bâtiment voilà
pas beaucoup plus ou ni moins que que
que la promotion il y a des matières
premières et des matériaux des fenêtres
et cetera ça c'est des des fournitures
dont les prix varient avec les prix pr
mondiaux du marché bon en ce moment on
est plutôt dans une période où ça se
calme mais il y a aussi des salaires
beaucoup de salaires et de l'énergie et
là ça se calme pas donc les coûts ne
vont pas
baisser massivement peuvent se calmer un
peu les et les normes il faut se
calmer on a déjà des normes extrêmement
performantes il faut s'y tenir un
certain temps le temps que le marché se
remette sur
pied nos marges elles sont faible à
moins de 5 % on sait pas bien
travailler l'impôt sur les logements
sociaux il faut le supprimer parce que
on est obligé de le répercuter et vous
voyez donc que l'équation est assez
tendue et que ça va être compliqué de
régénérer une nouvelle offre aux
conditions de demain de ces équations de
demain avec des prix qui doivent être
plus bas et que la conséquence de ça
c'est qu'on va produire moins et donc on
va ajuster nos outils industriels notre
capacité C de production à une
production plus basse de 30 % que ce
qu'on faisait jusqu'ici peut-être
probablement et ce qui est l'inverse de
ce qu'il faudrait
faire merci beaucoup moi je vais être
obligé de vous quitter je vais laisser
peut-être mes mes collègues vous poser
quelques
questions ce qui est vrai aussi c'est
qu'il y a une inertie donc si
aujourd'hui on se trouve dans cette
situation on peut penser que dans les 3
4 années à venir malheureusement les
choses ne vont pas se
redresser le plus rapidement possible
parce que voilà il y a l'inertie aussi
et et la politique du logement elle
s'inscrit aussi dans le temps long ce
qui est voilà aussi contraignant par
rapport à à la crise du logement que
nous connaissons je sais pas si Amel ou
Viviane vous avez une question moi je
suis obligé de vous laisser je vous
remercie très sincèrement pour cette
audition et vos propos très intéressants
Viviane merci beaucoup très rapidement
je crois que Amel aussi a une contrainte
donc très rapidement on va poser nos
deux questions en même temps comme ça
vous voilà donc euh oui moi c'est merci
d'abord de de votre intervention et puis
j'avais une question moi on n' pas du
tout le même on voit bien que vous
proposez euh d'agir sur tous les niveaux
de la construction de logement et que
vous vous êtes absolument il y a besoin
de construire or on n pas un
gouvernement ni ni un le trésor qui nous
ce type de discours on est plutôt dans
le fait que ben non il y a assez de
logement et qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
cette idée que les logement vacant
pourrai compenser le manque de
construction que nous on voit bien
actuellement sur la question de la
densité comment on faire aussi pour
aller contre l'acceptabilité sociale de
cette densité qui est quand même un
sujet et puis juste une dernière petite
question sur inciter les mèes bâtisseurs
à construire en fléchant plus de
recettes que est-ce que vous pouvez nous
nous détailler un petit peu cette cette
mesure tout d'abord merci beaucoup
encore une fois pour tout tous ces
éléments apportés très très précis et
concrets je voudrais revenir peut-être
sur deux sujets celui du foncier vous en
avez déjà quand même parlé assez
longuement mais cette c'est pas une
contrainte c'est cette problématique du
coup du foncier qui ne va pas aller en
s'arrangeant avec en effet cette
réglementation dont on a besoin vous
d'ailleurs vous l'avez dit clairement on
sait aujourd'hui qu'on va devoir ce zan
même s'il est problématique il s'impose
à nous pour des questions de de
réchauffement climatique et et vous avez
évoqué quelques solutions hein notamment
avec ces emprunts peut-être différents
qui permettrait pour le demandeur de
pouvoir même sur un immobilier cher de
pouvoir accéder mais on sait qu'on ne va
pas pouvoir continuer comme cela et que
le coût du logement de toute façon va
devoir baisser que la part du foncier
est de plus en plus importante dans le
coût de construction on parle de 20 à 40
% aujourd'hui selon selon les projets
est-ce qu' aujourd'hui vous avez des
propositions sur la la façon de j'aime
bien le terme neutraliser parce que B ça
risque d'être compliqué mais en tout cas
de neutraliser le cooup du foncier la
deuxième question mais qui est plutôt
une question voilà je je vous je vais
vous taquiner un petit peu parce que
j'ai bien aimé votre très juste
d'ailleurs comparaison avec et je
partage d'ailleurs votre point de vue
avec ce qui se fait aujourd'hui chez nos
voisins étrangers sur cette nécessité
d'accompagner la demande maintenant ce
qui ce qui ce qui nous est opposé à ces
propositions c'est c'est évidemment les
restrictions budgétaires quand je dis
restriction c'est surtout nos capacités
et surtout notre surendettement qui fait
qu'à aujourd'hui c'est une option qui
est malheureusement mise de côté et
pourtant vous l'avez dit et redit on
sait à quel point le logement est vous
l'avez dit un vrai besoin vital et donc
il c'est facile à dire hein c'est facile
à dire mais c'est un choix voilà qu'on
doit faire un choix politique et donc ma
question par rapport à cela c'est de
savoir vous en avez évoqué quelques-unes
mais quelle mesure à très court terme on
peut mettre en place mesure qui ne sera
qui coûterait rien vous avez parlé de
réglementation mais voilà je vous
explique un petit peu vous avez déjà
évoqué quelques solutions mais
concrètement à court terme que peut-on
faire pour relancer la demande des
mesures qui ne coûteraient quasi rien et
puis dernière chose alors là c'est
plutôt je reprends ma je prends ma
casquette d'élu local j'ai toujours mal
du mal à entendre même si c'est une
réalité que les maires ou certains
maires
on freine en tout cas les constructions
ou en tout cas aujourd'hui ne répondent
pas ou n'optimise pas leur plu ce qui
est une réalité on le on le vit encore
une fois en tant qu'élu local et ça
rejoint une de tes remarques he sur
l'acceptabilité je reste quand même
convaincu que nous allons rentrer dans
une telle période tendue euh en terme de
logement que cette acceptabilité va
aussi évoluer c'estàdire que quand on a
ses propres enfants qui ont du mal à se
loger à un moment on peut entendre aussi
qu'on peut et qu'on doit construire
devant chez nous donc il y a une
question de temps il y a un décalage
dans le temps qui intégré qui va être
intégré je parle de la population qui
est déjà par les par les maires les
mares ont une autre contrainte c'est euh
c'est oui les leviers ou en tout cas les
incitations qui vont les pousser à
construire donc il y a la population
mais a aussi les incitations mais
toujours encore une fois une question de
moyens et donc de volonté véritablement
politique donc c'est plutôt là pas une
question mais une remarque mais je le
dis aussi sur l'acceptabilité pardon je
pense vraiment que le temps et la crise
parce que ce qui est terrible dans ce
que vous avez dit c'est que elle ne va
pas aller en s'arrangeant puisque là
malheureusement on va avoir de TR années
très compliquées hein le temps du
lancement des des programmes fait que ça
va être compliqué de de de déclencher ça
très vite mais mais le temps va faire
malheureusement dans ce sens-là en tout
cas son œuvre
merci merci beaucoup je j'ai beaucoup de
questions fort intéressantes euh sur les
les logements vacans et le besoin de
logement sur les logements
vacants ils sont pas au bon endroit dans
immobilier il y a immobile voilà donc
ils sont à de caseville et à maobug qui
sont des villes que je respecte
totalement mais c'est pas là où on en a
besoin euh où ils sont dans le rural et
c'est pas loin où on a besoin donc les
intello en particulier un d'entre eux
qui disent il y a plein de logements
vacants en France on a plus besoin de
construire
euh se trompe lourdement et le savent
donc c'est de la malhonnêteté
intellectuelle caractérisée il suffit de
regarder une carte et de voir où sont
les logements vacances ça prend 5
minutes euh donc aujourd'hui plus
personne ne dénit je crois qu'on a
besoin de de loger plus les Français que
ce soit en réhabilitant ou en
construisant ou en transformant des
bureaux ou en transformant des zones
commerciales et c'est pour ça que je
cité cette étude
Ush HTC voilà pour une fois il y a des
gens qui ont voilà c'est récent ça c'est
sorti cette semaine 58000 logements par
an voilà le besoin donc on peut chipoter
dire non c'est 450000 mais c'est c'est
pas zéro en aucun cas en aucun cas et il
faut je crois que ça c'est l'un des
grands acquis de ces 2 ans de de combat
qu'on a mené avec un certain nombre de
gens c'est que à part la chief économist
du Trésor qui continue de dire qu'on a
plus besoin de construire elle est toute
seule c'est fini elle elle elle prêche
dans le désert elle est toute seule
c'est faux il faut arrêter et qu'est-ce
qu'il y a derrière une espèce de doxa de
BI et ou là là le logement ça coûte cher
donc n nous engageons pas dans une
politique de logement parce que ça
coûtera forcément quelque chose au
budget de l'État mais on a dépassé ce ce
stade aujourd'hui c'est la crise c'est
la bombe elle est en train d'exploser
les gens sont dans la rue renoncent à
leurs études enfin bon j'arrête parce
que donc ces gens sont totalement
disqualifié il y en a plus beaucoup vous
en avez peut-être entendu une elle est
seule elle est toute seule et quelques
autres àerill qui suivent cette doxa
euh après euh le
l'AC l'acceptabilité de la densité moi
je crois qu'il faut montrer des projets
danse réussi et c'est pour ça que je
parlais d'ici les Mau ici
cord-eville on a fait un
projet où il fait bon vivre et qui est
je crois un modèle de densité heureuse
sur un terrain qui n'était pas si grand
que ça et c'est complètement réussi et
et donc il faut expliquer aux Français
que
c'est pas des tours de de 100 m de haut
et des courants d'air entre les tours
comme certains grandes villes grandes
villes nord-américaine c'est un habitat
plus dense d'ailleurs Paris est une des
villes les plus denses du monde he vous
le savez donc c'est ça c'est une densité
à la parisienne et et c'est c'est
beaucoup et ça permet de bien utiliser
le foncier et même de dégager de temps à
autre des espaces verts des espaces de
respiration c'est très mixte aussi et
c'est c'est très mix puisquon fait du
commerce en pied d'immeu des restaurants
des cinémas des forêts urbaines et du
social des crèches des écoles venez voir
ici les moulinau notre projet qui est un
vrai démonstrateur on vous fera visiter
avec grand
plaisir après j'ai très mal écrit les
mes bâtisseurs les recettes voilà
voilà oui c'est je pense
que je qu'il faut inciter les m à
bâtir on a rompu le lien entre la la
taille de la population d'une ville et
ses recettes
fiscales avec la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation qui est compensé sur une
base
historique
donc et on a rompu l'idée avec les
comment dire le les directiv de sur la
hausse des des des dépenses des villes
,3 % je crois le lien avec la hausse de
la population donc si je je fais
j'accrois ma population j'accueille des
nouveaux habitants je n'ai pas plus de
recette fiscal que si je ne le fais pas
ça c'est un vrai problème
euh
c'est et quand on crée même en partant
dans les directions légitimes des effets
pervers il faut les
corriger suppéair oui des écoles des
crèches des coûts supplémentaires donc
plus de coup pas plus de recette
pourquoi je j'accueillerai plus de
population mon voisin mon m voisin n qu'
s'en occuper lui qui a du terrain ou je
sais pas quoi donc oui probablement
qu'il faut rétablir ce lien entre la
taille de la population l'accueil de
nouveaux habitants et les recettes
fiscales c'est la FP d'ailleurs qui
proposait de flécher une fraction de TVA
et voilà après il y a un C nom d'idée
flécher de la TVA TVA c'est toujours
assez tabou
euh euh
le le foncier et son
coût comment peut-on faire oui alors moi
mon idée ça n'est pas de dissocier la
propriété du
foncier de celle de l'appartement dire
j'habite dans un appartement mais le
terrain est pas à moi je paye un loyer
qui est le BRS voilà je trouve ça trop
compliqué et en plus le législateur a
privé l'acquéreur de la plusvalue donc d
déjà faut avoir fait quand même beaucoup
d'études pour comprendre le montage et
quand on a compris que à la
fin on n' pas accès à la même plusvalue
sur le logement que celui qui a acheté
normalement on a moyennement envie donc
je pense le BRS c'est une alternative à
la location si je cherche à louer dans
une ville et que je ne trouve pas parce
qu'il y a pas assez de parc locatif j'ai
peut-être intérêt à acheter en BRS parce
que c'est moins mal que de pas trouver
en en location et toute façon la vraie
propriété j'ai pas les moyens mais à
part
ça je pense que ce n'est pas la solution
donc moi je propose de
dissocier terrain et logement non pas
sur le plan de la propriété mais sur le
plan du financement c'est ça le crédit
hybride à la Suisse c'est on traite
différemment le crédit sur le terrain et
le crédit sur l'appartement le crédit
sur l'appartement c'est un crédit normal
le crédit sur le terrain c'est un crédit
infin c'est bête de consommer de
l'épargne des français surtout quand ils
en ont pas pour rembourser un bien le
terrain qui est rare qui est cher et
dont la valeur ne va faire qu'augmenter
la banque n'a pas besoin de cela elle
peut tout à fait prêter ses 30 % en se
garantissant sur les 100 % de de de la
propriété pleine donc voilà ma solution
pour finalement faire que le coût du
foncier pèse moins sur l'acquéreur et
sur la mensualité de l'acquéreur euh
même si le foncier reste cher
euh
alors
euh le budget de l'État notre
surendettement
national il y a plein de mesures qui ne
coûte rien au budget de l'État il y a
trois catégories il y a ce qui ne coûte
pas plus que les 38 milliards qu'on
dépense aujourd'hui ce qui ne coûte rien
et ce qui coûte plus
is
donc moi je m'insurge déjà contre l'idée
que prélever moins c'est de
subventionner ça c'est une idée
tordue c'est une idée absolument tordue
c'est mais c'est incroyable quand on
réfléchit bien taxz moins ça voudrait ça
serait subventionné non taxer moins
c'est taxer moins c'est pas
subventionner subventionner c'est
prendre dans une poche et donner à
quelqu'un le lui prendre moins ce n'est
pas le subventionner donc c'est la la
première chose donc on prélève 90
milliards on en dépense 38 ça fait quand
même plus 52 donc arrêtons dire que le
logement les aides au logement ruine
l'état après c 38 probablement peut-être
qu'on peut mieux les
utiliser je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
on avait pas besoin du Pinel et du PTZ
ces 10 dernières années 2010 2020 on en
a besoin
maintenant il faut donner à l'acheteur
individuel une raison d'acheter un T2 de
le mettre en
location et pour ça il faut le taxer
moins le taxer moins ça veut pas dire le
subventionner voilà d'ailleurs ça veut
même probablement dire remplir les
caisses de l'État parce que si on
stimule la demande et que l'offre suit
on a de la TVA à 10 ou peut-être si
c'est du logement intermédiaire ou 20 %
si c'est du logement libre qui rentre
dans les caisses de l'État au lieu de la
faire sortir comme aujourd'hui avec les
Mo- 4 ou - 10 que je je vous ai évoqué
euh et puis il y a toutes les mesures de
simplification un autre idée de de
crédit hybride à la Suisse ça coûte pas
1 € budget de l'État mais pas un rien il
suffit de tendre le bras du Haut Conseil
de stabilité financière voilà chose que
on devrait faire absolument voilà je dis
ça devant les caméras mais je l'ai déjà
dit publiquement parce que ces gens-là
font du zel ils font du zel ils
appliquent leurs règles de manière
extrêmement restrictive je pas rentrer
dans la technique il y a deux façons
compter le t desff ils ont choisi la
plus pénalisante et tout est comme ça et
ces gens-là sont coresponsables de la
crise du logement en France et du fait
que tout est bloqué VO
après la
simplification respecter les PLU
accepter la densité ça ça coûte rien au
budget de l'État
euh donner le droit à un acquéreur
d'amortir son bien c'est le taxé moins
mais c'est pas le subventionner
donc
voilà et puis les mesures qui ne coûtent
rien obblet de il faut les prendre vite
on sait que prendre les mesures qui
coûtent c'est plus compliqué et enfin
sur les M moi je crois que en fait c'est
pas la faute des m ce qui se passe il y
a Bernard de vert le fondateur d'habitat
humaniste qui a fait un article hier qui
est très bien qui dit on devrait tous
faire notre examen de conscience le
matin en arrivant nous tous partie
prenante acteur du logement on devrait
dire est-ce que j'ai fait quelque chose
de bien pour loger les Français ou
est-ce que j'ai fait l'inverse il faut
prendre l'habitude de dire oui oui je
vais vous délivrer votre permis oui je
vais vous donner votre densité oui vous
avez raison on va pas faire des T4 T5
qui se vendent
pas oui on va essayer d'aller vite
plutôt que d'aller lentement oui on va
essayer d'éviter les recours et si on
fait tous comme ça on va produire du
logement bien et plus vite mais
aujourd'hui le système c'est tout
l'inverse c'est une machine à dire non
ou une machine à répondre lentement donc
c'est ça qui va pas et et je conclurai
là-dessus parce que vous êtes vous êtes
pressé mais faisons notre examen de
conscience ce n'est plus l' l'heure de
se chipoter de se renvoyer la balle
d'inventer des trucs super compliqués on
fait un métier simple on fabrique des
logements que les Français peuvent
acheter ou louer avec leurs moyens qui
sont ce qu' sont pour y arriver il faut
dire oui et avancer et se demander tout
le temps si on est allé dans cette
direction si on le fait tous toutes les
parties prenantes on va y
arriver je vous en
prie merci beaucoup c une bonne
conclusion belle conclusion merci
encoreés ça c'est le document en a
quelquesun sur la comparaison avec les
pays européens comme je vous l'avais pas
envoyé monsieur Monier je l'ai je vlais
apporter